the five most amazing opening ideas
of the legend gary kasparov gary
was famous for some of his opening innovations
and we're gonna look at his five most famous here
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel otherwise i'll be on your case
i'll find you i'll track you down first example
like most of these examples is taken from a world
championship match the most important kind of
match in the world the world championship match
yes it is and it's against karpov with the black
pieces played in moscow in 1985 and this was a key
win for kasparov who started with the sicilian
and they went into the so-called tamanov sicilian
where we have this normal structure here knight
b5 still one of the main lines we don't let that
knight in so d6 and now c4 the so-called moroxy
bind situation black develops and after knight
to c3 a6 knight to a3 karpov must be feeling
very happy with himself here because he's got
a little bind on the center of the board and he's
controlling gripping the position up to this point
in time everyone had gone bishop e7 and black's
a little bit worse but gary now comes up with
d5 oh i have some of that cup off and this move
just breaks open the position at the cost of a
whole pawn but look at black's pieces they
just fly into the game this gave gary a very
important win maybe one of the most important
wins on his way to becoming world champion
in 1985. karpov now took a couple of times on this
square and you might be thinking where's black's
compensation white has this tremendous extra pawn
what is compensation lies in this night here this
knight is a beautiful piece it can't be kicked
away because white has a knight on that square
and after both sides develop very normally you
can see black brings all his pieces into play
takes the open file pushes on the queen side
and eventually sticks that knight on d3 and this
knight is certainly worth a pawn it controls e1 is
in the middle of the board there was a fret of b4
here and gary went on to win with his vast piece
of superiority here so a lovely idea that d5 and
really a slap in the fish slapping the fish well
cardboard was actually called a fish by coachnoy
but i meant to say face with a fish by casper
aroff let's just move on to the next one shall we
the next one the world championship match
between karpov and kasparov again in 1990 new
york now i'm gonna go through the opening moves
with these things very quickly so you can see
where the novelties came from and this one was a
king's indian defense one of gary's best openings
best weapons and they got to a position that has
been seen many times before on about move 13 where
black has just broken with d5 but white keeps the
position closed down and up to this point most
players have just played bishop d7 and white's
considered to be a little bit better because of
the pressure there but gary plays a phenomenal
idea he plays rook takes e3 i remember the first
time i saw it so i was like what is this amazing
concept because there's no immediate follow-up
after queen takes e3 for example knight
g4 doesn't even work that well because the
knight takes c6 and the queen is attacked but
the idea is just queen f8 there is now a threat
of knight g4 and black's going for dark square
compensation he's trying to prove that his bishop
is actually stronger than a rook because white has
weakened his dark squares with some idea like f3
and i think for a beginner like i was when i first
saw this it was a very hard idea to get to grips
with but look at how black's pieces just have
great activity i'm going to whiz through the moves
this bishop beautiful this rook gains a
very useful line there the rook now comes in
and now the last piece is developed and
black is very solid in the center as well
knight b2 the knight now opens up so the bishop
gets active that knight may even be able to attack
on the dark squares white forces the rook over
here but gary now threatens knight g3 the queen
gets its way around and now bishop d4 diverting
the queen away from the king's side to force okay
only a draw but let's remember a draw with black
in the world championships is a great result and
the whole concept i just found simply astonishing
there giving up the rook for the dark squares for
long-term play positional compensation well i'm
going for lots of lessons in the kingdom defense
and this one karpov kasparov again i'm going to
whiz through the moves it happens on move 19. in a
position that's been seen many times before this
was in tilburg not the world championships and
they played the mainline kings indian where white
attacks on the queen side black on the king side
and they get to a position which is considered
up to the point in time by firing 2b a little
bit better for white because you can see
white's progress on the queen side is coming
very quickly white gaining a load of space
but here we see a simply astonishing idea
now previously up to this point black
had tried stuff like f4 but after g4
things are closed down and not really well
you're losing a piece there and other ideas
well where is the compensation well gary now
comes up with an idea which just again must have
taken carp off by surprise knight takes g3
poor old karpov so often just taken by surprise
and this is an astonishing idea let's remember
these opening novelties were often found when
computers weren't strong so they're found
before the tournament by a team of helpers
the idea of this is to bring the other knight in
and to target g3 now after f4 the game got very
complex and eventually ended in a draw but let me
just show you one of the main concepts behind this
which is if king g2 well now we can do the double
sacrifice knight takes g3 and after king takes f4
check it might look like it's only going to be
a draw with some perpetual but black is winning
eventually the black queen will force the king
into h1 and as soon as we get this situation we
don't have to repeat we can try to get the rook
in the game with g5 and funnily enough there's no
way white can stop this maneuver so white is lost
the king's in defense in gary's hands was just a
spectacular weapon study his games if you want to
learn about this opening yet another king's indian
defense this time against kramnik in 1994. it was
only a blitz game but gary was able to unleash
yet another astonishing peace queen sacrifice
this time now they follow the mainline king's
indian and again we're going to get to the main
position after normal moves and the main position
does occur on move 12 in a position that has been
seen before up to this point g5 queen e8 have
been tried but now kasparov plays one of the most
astonishing ideas of the time and still nowadays
knight on f takes e4 he leaves his queen on pre
and he only gets two pieces and a pawn for it
after the fourth sequence bishop takes queen
knight takes c3 the queen has to guard the
bishop and now rook takes d8 but what has
black got in compensation but he's got this
fantastic bishop which will come to life
after e4 he's also got tremendous activity
with the two knights here these knights are very
tricky but maybe most importantly white doesn't
have any harmony with his pieces so black can just
simply improve his situation by pushing forwards
of course kramnik probably thought he was winning
here judging by any of his interviews but things
quickly went wrong after knight takes a2 and
knight b4 the knights jumping in the e4 pawn comes
up the board and white has not really managed
to do anything but black's been slowly improving
f5 f4 e3 ideas like this all coming together
and the position is just horrible for white
brilliant brilliant play and a brilliant idea yet
again from gary well to finish with we're actually
having an idea that gary had with the white
pieces and this was played against vichy van anad
in the world championship match pca world
championships in 1995. this started off again
with an opening that's been seen many times before
the open rule lopez and the open rule lopez is
after knight takes e4 black decides to grab
this one d4 now they follow established theory
all the way up to move 14 and on move 14 which
we're gonna see here with queen d3 white had
previously gone knight f3 because of course it
seems that there's lots of things dropping and
after the queen's come off it's considered
to be okay for black but gary came up with
some brilliant preparation it wasn't just one move
it was a little series of moves that he must have
had prepared in depth before arriving at the board
and it starts with bishop c2 this novelty now on
its own this doesn't seem like much but after
queen takes c3 knight b3 we see the real point
behind it gary's also going to give up his rook
but he's keeping anan's king stuck in the center
it can't castle and we have a queen coming out
to h5 and ant now took on b3 and only here maybe
did he see taking the queen would be very risky
for example if he grabs it here we come in with
check and you can well i think it's easy to see
just how dangerous things will become with these
ones coming g6 queen of freeze a great move and
all the light squares in black's position drop
the game continued in quite similar fashion
with knight d4 queen g4 queen takes a1
but after some more moves bishop h6 this is
just simply crushing for white the queen is
on pre and we're trying to get rid of the g pawn
for the white queen to come in i think i've even
looked at this position this move bishop h6 and
gary kasparov's most amazing moves of all time
but this is still probably his preparation and if
that bishop is taken we can even just come to f7
because there's no g6 to to block that so again
astonishing concepts by gary there brilliant play
and he really was a master of opening preparation
please like this video and do subscribe to the
channel it does help me make more if you want
to see more and again i think these ideas really
shaped modern day chess somebody's aggressive
intentions that gary came up with and maybe
you guys at home can even come up with a little
opening idea yourselves with this inspiration